could you do me a quick favor if you're
listening to this please hit the follow
or subscribe button it helps more than
you know and we invite subscribers in
every month to watch the show in person
the interim ufc
[Applause]
oh [ __ ] i know when it's all said and
done when i'm dead my name will be
remembered in history why does that
matter guys like us we're not meant to
fit in women just stand out but i felt
it it's addicting
so i need to do something that's gonna
just tame the beast
if not it's gonna seep in other ways i
wouldn't want it to in my life
are you happy i think 2013 was my great
depression i wasn't able to fight and
then i just felt like i don't deserve it
this world one thing i've seen they'll
build you up and then tear you down
people naturally just want to see you
fail
i had to take a hard look at myself and
i put that pressure on myself like watch
this
i don't feel like i have anything to
hide i put things out there that i
probably shouldn't sometimes but that's
my way of being vulnerable where i'm
just like this is me
[Music]
[Applause]
so without further ado i'm stephen
bartlett and this is the diary of a ceo
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
israel yes thank you for being here
massive inspiration for me in so many
ways and i've watched your your rise
over the years with with inspiration and
um admiration for so many reasons
reason number one we have a i guess a
shared heritage in the fact that we're
both
nigerian
from
nigerian as well and so and your story
as i read it it sounded so bizarrely
like my story in so many ways and then
the other i mean i could there's an
exhaustive list of reasons why you've
inspired me personally but then seeing
what you've done with yourself as a
brand as a marketeer
again inspired me in a completely
different way and i'll never forget and
i played it for my girlfriend last night
your entrance
against robert whittaker for the first
time the first time and i'm like this
guy is breaking the rules
yeah the entrance um for me
that was uh i felt like that was my way
of
staying
away from the fight in the way because i
know that night robert was just like
stewing over the fight yeah he was
sleeping he wouldn't no no he wasn't
sleeping i'm sure he was just
worried about the fight thinking about
the fight just thinking about
but for me i was literally like fell
asleep with my phone in my hand watching
my rehearsals for that entrance like
this is going to look sick replay
probably replayed it like 60 times the
night before and i fell asleep with my
phone in my hand watching that just the
rehearsals so i was like there was no
paralysis over analysis i was just like
focused on how sick that was gonna look
and it was fun for me it was my way of
authentically expressing myself
with my roots and dancing
and just being creative so when it was
time to show out you know i showed out
you know and it was my show this time
like you know um when robert and calvin
gaslam's fight
fell out the morning of the fight before
two three four
um that was a that was a melbourne night
yeah red laver arena melbourne as well i
want to do an interest and then dana was
like uh
not allowed nah can't have it this isn't
that right
so when it was 243 i was like look this
is my show
i'm doing this entrance i don't give a
[ __ ] what do you think and yeah i made
sure i didn't look how it turned out it
was iconic and you realize though
because when i remember i must have been
3am here when i was watching that
i'm thinking this guy's put more
pressure on himself like he didn't need
to plan himself he has to win now
exactly i love that i like to gamble
but i like to gamble at the highest
level i had to gamble with like the
biggest stakes you know because i feel
like whenever i get that win
over that and i it just it just feels
that much better and i feel like
i don't know you just ah there's a
feeling i don't know how to describe it
but it's just because you know people
are watching that just like [ __ ] life
but she doesn't like me like
[ __ ] hope this gets dropped oh this
guy gets knocked the [ __ ] out you know
he thinks he's the man walking out
dancing all that [ __ ] so you know people
naturally just want to see you fail and
like this guy thinks he's that good
on a that was 57 127 people in
attendance and i put that pressure on
myself like watch this
and yeah for me there's something
special about just overcoming that that
just gives me that
that rush
speaking of entrances then you were born
in nigeria um as i said i'm half
nigerian and then you moved to new
zealand what what was the reason why
your parents decided to take you out of
nigeria and move you to another country
i think it was um
initially better recognized
tertiary education because you know i
mean
when i'm in new zealand i sometimes i'll
be
you know talking to a cab driver and you
find out that he was a medical doctor
back in sri lanka or back in india and
then moved over to
you know
nz or the western world for a quote
unquote better life
and their
their qualifications aren't recognized
in the western world you know but
they're a surgeon or something crazy
back home so then they have they're
forced to take these um i guess
millionaire jobs or
start up a new business and yeah they
wanted us to have better recognized
tertiary education
yeah worked out all right for me
but you were really smart anyway in in
nigeria when you got when you got to new
zealand you were smarter than the class
i remember you saying that they thought
you were yeah oh yeah but i was like
the that was a form one i remember like
it was um we're doing two times table
and i was just like
yeah
i knew the song in my head
finished and i remember when i felt
everyone was like
whoa
like and i'm the runt of our people
trust me like i'm not the smartest you
know kid in the class
back in nigeria so when that happened i
was just like
what's up with these kids like this is
easy this is light work i did form one
actually three times so i did it first
time when i was 10 years old
in nigeria bell's boarding school and
then when i moved to ghana for about a
year and a bit i had to do
you know about yeah a year and a half to
do primary six and then form one again
and then when i moved to new zealand i
had to do form one again then i skipped
form two and then went straight to form
three because it was i just kept there
was oh he's too young you know he can't
in each country was like he's too young
to be in form one so
yeah uh
but i wasn't i wasn't the most
academically gifted kid i'm smart but
i'm smart in different ways yeah
when um when i was reading about your
story the the other part that really
resonated with me was
we we came from botswana and we moved to
a place called plymouth in devon and
cornwall which is like a farmland it's
like if you go right now yeah yeah yeah
four hours into the the end of the
country that way yeah where it's all
cows and fields yep and all white people
yeah that's where we moved and we're the
only black family my mom's nigerian yeah
and um that process of trying to figure
out why i was different to my classmates
and why we were poorer in order i always
said i was like i never realized i was
black until i left nigeria yeah and it's
not that i didn't know my skin tone it
was just like i never knew like it was a
problem
you know i never knew like people
would you know i guess discriminate
against me because of my skin tone and
it was weird for me it was really weird
for me to kind of like almost like
another type of culture shock
like
uh the one i used was an example was
this kid who kept on riding by my house
in the weekend from school and were just
like her insults you know i had me at my
house in my house in the weekend he took
time out of his [ __ ] day on a
saturday night go back to your country
black and knees and then drive by
against oh you blacked this you better
lie
i literally was just like did i do
something to this kid
i know his name even i remember his name
not his last name but i was just like
like what did i do to this kid to like
did i did i do something and then
that monday
was it like monday or tuesday following
week he pulls up to me and said what a
black boy and i was having a bad day
already and this is after like lunch
time when it was about to
end and he pushed me and i remember just
wailing on him just threw him to his
cable beat his ass through his b-block
beat his ass and i just i was crying the
whole time just beating them up and i
wasn't a fighter back then but i was
just fed up and pissed off like what the
[ __ ] is this kid like first of all
you're asking me all weekend and then at
school you're harassing me yeah he never
did that again after that yeah
what was your relationship like with
your race at that point because i i got
to be honest i started like relaxing my
hair and i started i did and i was
trying to i was trying to be white i was
trying to fit in like there was a point
even like i started to try and talk like
the kiwi kids i tried to like use the
same slang i still do but like just
because i'm part of the culture but like
i really tried to like
fit and fit in and i don't know what you
mean by relaxed i was relaxing my hair
because i thought it was cool
you know it wasn't because i was trying
to fit in but there was bits and pieces
where i was just like man
because you everyone just wants to
belong you know especially as kids you
know you just want to be part of a tribe
or fit in but then
yeah when it took me a while to realize
that i wasn't meant to fit in like guys
like us we're not meant to fit in women
to stand out so eventually i had to kind
of stand it took me a while to kind of
learn how to stand ten toes deep in my
own light but yeah i was there at one
point you know trying to fit in and
trying to make sure almost
like even during lunch time if i wanted
to go to the top shop right
i would take the long way i would like a
rat or mouse i would scare you along the
edges of the school so i don't get
[ __ ] with
and it would take longer twice as long
three times as long but at least i
didn't have to just walk through and get
[ __ ] with you know on the way to the
talk shop or something because i spent
most of my time in the library during
lunch times
um i think in form three
yeah just because
safe in the library what do you mean by
getting [ __ ] with what would happen if
you walk directly to the tuck shop and i
saw him i just
throw an apple at you or you know
something stupid like someone might run
up behind you in town downtrow you
you know
or trip you
or just chase you trying to beat you up
for fun and people my kids are stupid
you know you're i was in a boys school
as well so you know it's all these boys
i know like all just pent up emotions
and unresolved trauma and don't know
what to do with the newfound hormones
and then it's just like
like little chimps and yeah see that's
however i know yeah definitely so it's
like
yeah uh
we didn't know i for me it was just
yeah as an adult now i look at it i'm
just like man we didn't know what the
[ __ ] we're doing like who let us like
who let us outside
you know but um it's all part of the
learning experience i feel it's all part
of growing pains like i know when i have
kids i know exactly what i'm going to
tell them and uh how to handle
themselves if you know what i mean
what are you going to tell them
well one of the ones that's hit hard hit
first to be honest like okay like this
whole thing i remember like you know oh
don't don't hit them first you you know
like if they touch you then you i'm like
nah [ __ ] all that because
the first punch matters
the first punch matters so if someone
like you know is talking to me and
pushing me around pushing me around
smack them
like they'll learn first like first hand
like okay don't [ __ ] with that kid even
if you might win at least he's not going
to be a like make it not easy for them
to [ __ ] with you
you know what i mean
that's one thing i'm definitely going to
teach my kids is like just make sure
you're unfucking
unfuckable with
yeah
when i look back at my early years and
you know having studied a bit of
childhood psychology i realized how like
formative and important those values are
and we we're basically as adults like
living out the stories we told ourselves
about ourselves as kids and yeah seeking
validation from all the things that are
changing
exactly yeah
what what was left behind as you became
an adult a lot talk to me about one
thing
i can't want to go deep
definitely
being a kid that moved from nigeria to
new zealand right
and trying to fit in
i ended up being a people pleaser as a
kid i didn't realize that because i'm
trying to fit i'm trying to please
everyone and then you don't realize how
that follows you into adult life so
there's times and it's still once in a
while you'll be surprised it raises ugly
head but i'm able to like identify that
monster now and i'm just like i know
what that is boom and i kill it straight
away
so i've learned that over years though
but then that people please are still
still a part of me you know because it
was a way of surviving you know i'll
just make sure these guys are cool don't
[ __ ] with me i could you know and i just
kind of appease them
yeah that's one thing definitely that
that was the result of just i guess
trying to fit in it's just people
pleasing and it's not it's not the best
way to live it's not the best way to
live because you can't make everyone
happy and someone's always going to find
something wrong with what you're doing
or how you're living or whatever so
yeah i it took me a long time but
eventually i got to the point where i
just don't
i really don't care what anyone else
thinks apart from those who i give a
[ __ ] about i care what they think but
anyone else who's not really i guess i
don't have any emotional attachment to
[ __ ] them
like bernie mac said [ __ ] him yeah and
when you say people pleasing
to be to be to be specific in the
examples of you being a people pleaser
do you mean
on social media or like to the public
ever before social media or would you
mean before social media this is when i
was a kid like in high school people
pleasing as in the sense of like you
know
um
someone asked you to do something you
might not want to do it but you'll do it
just because you just sure you want to
fit in
because that guy you know he
you know i guess he's one of the first
15
jocks who played rugby or whatever and
he's just like oh you know
i'll do what he says just because you
want to get that it's almost like clout
or social currency
you know what i mean so yeah things like
that but um
yeah it took me a long time like i said
to learn and realize those things this
is a lot of self-reflection
years of self-reflection and realizing
because a lot of people don't even
realize they're running on
old you know childhood trauma like a lot
of everyone is so you have to find a way
to sit down and just access that with
yourself through therapy is one of the
best ways and then you just work you
it's like reverse engineering like where
does that come from you know why why am
i like that why am i why do i have that
attitude why do i think like that and
then yeah you and your therapist kind of
work that back and realize
you know where that comes from
as i was reading through your story and
you know you sit here as this
unbelievable ufc champion
and then as i read through your story
there's all these little subtle hints of
what almost sounds a bit like imposter
syndrome at certain times like this guy
not believing that he's deserving of
what he's achieved and it's it really
sits in contradiction to
the guy that did that backflip coming
out against
where did that come from tell me about
that um
i think some of just same thing trauma
childhood trauma some of that stuff um
i've dealt with it very well now
to the point where it's like there was
times um i used an example when uh i was
thinking i would i was speaking to
forbes
not long ago and we we dived into this a
little bit so when i when i beat rob
right
one of my gifts to myself i bought
myself a mclaren 720s nice and
i um
the first day i got it i remember i
drove to the gym um this was at
peak you know time at the gym maybe six
5 30 p.m or whatever
and i didn't pocket at the front of the
gym i parked it at the back of the gym
and i showed some of my teammates like
my close close actual teammates not the
people that go to the gym because
sometimes a lot of people like to be
like i'm israel's teammates like no you
just go to the same gym as me doesn't
mean we're teammates so i parked it at
the back of the gym and then after my
teammates finished working i was like yo
come check this out
and i showed them and i was like like
[ __ ] look at this [ __ ] like because they
know how
the work i put in i work hard
but then i'm like man i'm not the i'm
not the best student in the gym so
imagine if i can do this imagine what
they can do so i kind of just just to
share the
share my joy
and then
you know
unfortunately especially in new zealand
there's this tall puppy syndrome and is
that green eyed monster and i've been
that kid so it's easy for me to
recognize it on other people when you've
when you've had it with yourself
um
so someone said something you know i
must be nice and i start to hear
rumblings of i know it happens are you
for me it was the same thing i was just
like i didn't expect that from someone
that i cared about to to have that kind
of rhetoric like oh
and then i heard you know maybe you know
like other people did more deserving
people
what i know yeah and they're kind of
just pissing me off loving people yeah
at the gym because they work harder than
me right right and like i said i didn't
if i wanted to flex i would have parked
it in the front of the gym like
you know look at my new whip
and just to like flex and just show off
or whatever but not parked in the back
of the gym where only like seven people
saw it and the seven people that i
really give a [ __ ] about and i wanted
them to see like look look at this [ __ ]
like [ __ ] if i can do this imagine what
you can do
so when i heard that
i didn't drive it for a week i just i
just felt [ __ ] driving i remember
driving at home and i just felt like
[ __ ] i just parked it in the garage and
i just left it there for a week i didn't
drive it because i felt
like i let those words from that person
i gave a [ __ ] about seep into me
and then it sat with me and then i just
felt like oh yeah i mean i don't deserve
it you know you know other people work
harder than me at the gym this and that
right or right or wrong but then it took
like i said about a week
over that week because i mean it was a
[ __ ] sick car i literally didn't
drive it for a week and got to the point
that i realized during that week that
towards the end like well that's
subjective if they don't think i deserve
it that's their own opinion that's
subjective that's what they believe
i don't have to believe that and like
you said that is that that impostor
syndrome thing started to creep in i was
like look maybe they don't think i
deserve it but one thing no one can ever
take away from me is that i earned it
every [ __ ] thing i have i earned it
and i earned this [ __ ] whip and i
have a right to drive this thing and
flex and once i got over that hurdle of
my head boom i was in that [ __ ] and i
was whipping it around but yeah it's
like that imposter syndrome thing
creeped crept in when i heard that from
and it was through the grapevine as well
but then i was from someone i really
liked i i was like man why would he say
that i just i just and people learn this
is over that's a long time ago you know
this is whitaker fight but
it's something it said more about them
than it does about me
you know what i mean it's it says more
about them than it does about me so i
shouldn't have let that affect me at all
but i did because i gave a [ __ ] with
that person thought because they are
close person to me and unfortunately
sometimes it's the ones close to you
that will hurt you with that yeah
there's something really remarkably sort
of liberating and amazing to hear a ufc
champion talking about imposter syndrome
because it really does fit feel like
it feels like there's and this is i know
this is an obvious misconception it
really doesn't feel like someone with
your swag and confidence could
feel those things um you talked there
about therapy as well and when you spoke
to joe rogan about therapy
and about
after your ufc debut yeah that swirl you
went through i wrote about this in my
book
because i i got really compelled by the
this really bizarre thing that happened
in my life when my company joined the
stock market and i'm sat in my room in
manchester and it's worth 300 million
and i'm figuring out how much money that
means i've got
and it's feeling like the worst day of
my life
and then when i you know heard you
talking a little bit about how you felt
after your ufc fight hiding in the
toilet when people are pestering you to
ask you questions yeah and that annoying
dude sitting down next to you when you
tried to hide yeah after my ufc debut uh
the after party it was
after the fight it's always like i said
i get pulled in so many different
directions and it's just like it was my
first time in the ufc so i was my first
time experiencing all that
and
it's like coffee
it's a stimulant coffee's a stimulant so
after ufc debut and he's shot like the
way i did
you know i i stole the show i came in
there and i stole the show and it was
just like
cameras this oh we need you to interview
this split i'll come talk to this person
and then
i didn't get time to myself till i got
back home and when i was back home and i
was in my own house
and finally away from all the noise and
it's just like
and then i remember it's like coffee you
drink coffee you're you've got the
coffee high and then you crash so it's
literally that
like just lack of the stimulant and i
just crashed and i was like why am i sad
i just found myself being really sad and
i remember it's probably on my old phone
me documenting my recovery because i
like video diaries that is
i was like why am i sad like i made six
figures in my ufc debut
that's including the bonus as well yeah
and i'm just like there's no need to be
sad i [ __ ] killed that [ __ ] and
that's when i started to kind of like
take therapy seriously because okay this
is not going to be one of these
bad statistics you know that you hear
about in the in in entertainment so
yeah i um
i have to i guess take a take a hard
look at myself but then therapy help
with that because then you find the
right person who can kind of help you
i guess figure you out and all i do is
just ask you the right questions and
then show you
i guess yourself yeah
can you because i heard you say that you
picked up tools from therapy that helped
you sort of navigate all of that
attention in this new position you were
in what were the tools also um
it wasn't until i fought bronson that i
was able to go back home and just kind
of like
um i keep saying it's like i came back
from prison uh what do you call it like
we back into society regular life
normally you know it was until that was
my fourth ufc fight
but then each fight after that same
thing i go back home and i just like had
this crash
and i had to realize okay
this this is something that i can't have
happen constantly because it's not
healthy
a tool i can say that helped me um
one of the ones that helped with
charlemagne's book at the time shook
once anxiety playing tricks on me i read
that during the i finished reading that
actually during the um bronson fight
that fight week i finished reading that
and that i i got a lot of gems from that
book
but from therapy one
learning from therapy from my own
experiences talking to myself the
self-talk because you have we all have
negative self-talk
but looking in the mirror
and talking to yourself you know
speaking to yourself like you would to
someone you're giving advice to because
when you look in the mirror you humanize
yourself and i'll start to like you know
just have a conversation with myself
even like gee myself up if i want to
pick myself up things like that
so that's a tool that i feel like is
really underrated it looks crazy you
know standing from the mirror and
talking to yourself but
it's a really powerful tool if you know
how to use a right
fighters don't talk much about their
mental health
i think whitaker did the other day and
you you kind of thanked him and
applauded him for doing that for being
yeah
yeah i mean i i put him in a dark place
after that first fight and i understand
because guess what he was trying to do
the same thing to me um but guy respect
is i'm tyson fury because he's he spoke
about
that you know
to ends like and how dark he went he
went to like the depths of hell in his
own head
and then he's risen above it and he says
like he battles with every day i feel
like look there's
your spectrum of physical health
this is super healthy super ill
if you do not look after yourself
and your physical health you're going to
get physically ill same way if you don't
look after your mental health
you're going to get mentally ill
so i feel like if you're it's like
someone's saying like you know
i don't go to therapy [ __ ] all that [ __ ]
no
it's like well
do you
take vitamins do you go to the hospital
it's not something to be you know shy
like uh
whatever from it's i feel like you
should look after your mental health the
same way you look after your physical
health so once i learned how powerful
that was
i'm always on top of it i slip up
obviously because i'm human
and i get ill but yeah i always make
sure i'm i'm on point though
was that your hardest moment with your
mental health after that ufc debut in
your recollection
hmmm
not my hardest i think 2013 was my great
depression there was a time in 2013 that
life was just like
[Music]
a spiraling bad it's early 2013 i
remember at the time
my girl left me the business i was
working
with was failing work was [ __ ]
um
i had my jaw broken in 2012
and i wasn't able to fight so i really
had no like
not purpose but like something that i
was looking forward to
you know there was a time during that
2013 there was a time where
i was walking millie home one time and i
remember this is when i was really broke
and i remember just looking in this
dairy or like this corner store and i
was just like
i wish i could just go in there and be
like look
just give me the money you have
i don't want to hurt you or just give me
and i remember just like it was a
fleeting thought and i was like man and
that made me empathize with people i was
like
this is why some of them do it
they just have no other choice
obviously i'm not going to do it because
i'm not an idiot but i realize like this
is why some people do what they do
because they have no choice
they just want to eat
i was lucky enough that no matter how
bad it got i always had my parents
supporting me if i had my dad can you
please just loan me 100 bucks can you
just give me 200 bucks
they would always support me and i never
went to them often but whenever i needed
to
they were always there for me so i never
had to go to that point where i was and
i would have never anywhere because i'm
not stupid
you you refer to that moment as your
your great depression yeah 2013. what
got you out of that great depression
to be honest wants to have my fight so
then i fought in
june i believe
that year finally after six or seven
months because i had to take time off
after the surgery
fighting and then i realized my purpose
again like okay i know what i want to do
so i didn't fight for a long time
because it was
yeah it was just really
it was dark times not you know something
you're passionate about something you
what i moved to auckland to do and it
got taken away from me so then i wasn't
able to do what i wanted to do and then
once i got it back i just kind of read
and stated to myself like
i know who i am i know who the [ __ ] i am
so
yeah
there's something really sort of telling
about that that your lowest moment was
when you'd lost so much you'd lost
connection in terms of your girlfriend
and you lost orientation and purpose and
something to aim for in your life yeah
and you see that in young men i mean the
the single biggest killer of men in this
country under 45
yeah it's mad
and it's like how do we get young men to
have a sense of purpose and meaning in
their lives in the modern world how do
we get that back into them and it's
funnily enough i go to the gym around
the corner i could go to some posture i
go to the gym like down there yeah in
the in the end it's like 15 pounds a
month yeah and it's all black and asian
young men and when i'm in the gym i'm
looking around and i'm sat there
thinking like because now i'm on the
dragon's den they come up to me
sometimes but before that i was thinking
like the probably the best thing i could
do to help
um with suicide rates in this country
other than having these kind of
conversations is like
put loads of [ __ ] gyms in this
country yeah oh yeah you know what i
mean 100 i feel like we were talking
about earlier about
young men kids especially when they
become adolescents and they don't know
what to do all these new hormones
they're just filling up their bodies and
stuff like that they need an outlet
even for me i've said after this game's
done after i'm done with this fighting
[ __ ]
when i have a family at least
a couple of times a year i need to do
something that's gonna feel
like i'm about to die
i feel like i just need to do something
that's just gonna just i'm a bit of an
adrenaline junkie so i need to do
something that's gonna just like
tame the beast
if not i just feel like it's gonna seep
in other ways i wouldn't want it to in
my life you know so i need to find a way
to tame the beast and i feel like this
does martial arts was there's a quote
make savage of the body and civilize the
mind something like that you know what i
mean especially as young men honestly
like
they want to like you know sometimes
people want to kind of like
discredit
um athleticism or you know working out
or you're just a jock or listen i hate
drugs i was never drunk in school so i
have a really really special place in my
heart for them
but um yeah for me i just feel like just
being able to
own your masculinity in a way that's not
not toxic man i'm not talking toxic
masculinity but just being able to just
like
work out and a place where you can be a
man and just like throw weights around
or
i like i love rolling with my boys like
there's some i love lifting even during
lockdown i was lifting a lot but there's
something to be said when i have a guy
like my teammate brad riddell or carlos
or blood diamond you know on my back
trying to choke me out and then you know
three two one go and i have to fight the
choke
something primal about that that just
activates this part of my brain that i'm
just like
[ __ ] it's just yeah it gets me going
quick one as the seasons have begun to
change so has my diet and um
right now i'm just gonna be completely
honest with you i'm starting to think a
lot about
slimming down a little bit because over
the last couple of probably the last
four or five months my diet has been
pretty bad um and it started to show a
little bit really over the last two
months i go to the gym about 80 percent
of the time so i track it with 10 of my
friends in a whatsapp group and this
tracker online that we all use together
we call it fitness blockchain and i'm
currently at 81 percent
um so 81 of the days i've done a workout
in the last 150 days right so i'm going
to the gym about six times a week
that's been a little bit impacted by the
derivatio live tour but i'm trying to
stick to it and so one of the things i'm
doing now to reduce my calorie intake
and trying to get back to being
nutritionally complete and all i eat is
i'm having the
heel protein shake thank you hill for
making a product that i actually like
the salted caramel is my favorite i've
got the banana one here which is the one
my girlfriend likes but for me salted
caramel is
the one
juju worry about that when when all is
said and done like you're you're gonna
have these crazy moments of having like
60 000 people in this arena and coming
out doing these like i'm ready for it
yeah and then i'm ready for it the high
of that the adrenaline high of that um
when that's all when you're you know
when you're done with this game you said
you know when you lose the love of the
game or whatever it is
did you
do you punch you ponder what that moment
would be like for you
a little bit but i i'm ready for it in
the sense that i'm not attached to this
i've already i know i'm more than
fighting fighting there's more to life
than fighting so i'm not like one of
these guys who is attached like you know
i don't even know where my belt is right
now to be honest
i really don't know i'm not attached to
it i know i'm the [ __ ] champ i know
i'm who i am i know who i am and i'm a
champ without the belt it's just a fancy
tiara i've said that from the jump
but
i'm not attached to it to the sense that
it's my identity that this is all i am
so when it's all said and done and i'm
you know i'm not the ufc middleweight
champion anymore i'm retired i'm not
going to be like who am i
i know who i am
without the belt
so that's the that's the blessing in
that but a lot of people don't a lot of
people like you see them walk around
with the belt constantly
and they just stay attached to that like
that's who they are so when it's gone
and it's said and done that's why a lot
of people
who are supposed to be retired
still end up
talking
to the media and finding their way to
get their uh name in the in this in you
know in the spotlight because they're
addicted to that it's addicting trust me
i've been i've felt it it's addicting
attention that's that's the social
currency now attention even at the
highest level fame clout this is all
these are these are tangible things i've
seen it i've seen one that does to
people man funny story i saw this um
when i was in new york i felt brunson
right that week i saw this youtube video
of a guy in times square
in new york he was there regular
easy didn't you know just walking around
didn't get bothered and then
he went there at night time hired
entourage hired camera people undressed
apart
fake famous dude exactly fake famous guy
and they like oh and then the camera guy
asked him so how do you know uh david
and someone be like oh
i heard his last album i was pretty good
i heard a single on the radio or i saw
him in spite of people just lie through
their teeth you know and just say
whatever
they think he is and it's like you know
you obviously don't know the guy you can
just say i don't know who he is
you know and i've had that so when that
day that i'm sorry that that week in new
york i was doing a shoot for my brand
engage
in times square
i had jeff and like three other cameras
on me so there's like four cameras on me
you see people starting to gather around
like oh who's this guy and then some
people recognize me they start taking
pictures and then before i knew it i
started finding people who didn't even
know me yeah and they're just like i
just want to take a picture have you
ever had someone come up to you had this
when we went to costa rica yesterday and
they go hi um
who are you and i go oh um
[Music]
the worst one i remember was um
i've used this story a few times but i
was at this bar
in auckland
and there was a table of like four dudes
and two chicks and i could tell one of
the chick was like the center of
attention so when i came in the guys
were just like
no [ __ ] way stopping what the [ __ ] yo
just showing me love and all that and i
could see i could feel her energy and i
could see her from the corner of my eye
just like
and then she came up she was like
excuse me but who are you i was like uh
don't worry baby it's all good i was
talking to one of the guys taking photos
and like then she came back again trying
to talk to me i was just like and then
she came forcefully this time it's like
excuse me why is everyone giving a [ __ ]
who are you i don't know who you are and
i was like baby i don't know who you are
and i just bite her off i was like i
don't care you don't know who i am
you know but like the fact that she
wanted to let me know that she didn't
know who i was like it was gonna hurt my
feelings i was and i was just like baby
i don't know who you are and i remember
her face just like
she's not used to being treated like
exactly
i'm like i don't care i i forget who i
am all the time you know but the the
fact that she thought like it would
actually
hurt my feelings for her no no i'm like
what the [ __ ] are you you know how how
have you made sense with all this this
noise when you you walk through places
what the noise is the
the fame like what's your relationship
relationship with it i was thinking
about this the other night i was talking
to one of my friends and i was thinking
for me it's kind of just this thing
that's happening outside of me and i'm
observing it like a spectator i like
that i like that you know what i mean
there's no book on this [ __ ] so i've
always said like [ __ ] the fame but i
love the perks
i love the perks of fame but i just
i don't like being
famous you know what i mean have you
seen free brittany yeah yeah brother
there was a bit and that that was one of
my like i was getting anxiety watching
the first half of that there was a bit
she was driving and then she ran through
these red lights and the guys were like
look at her she's crazy i'm like yeah
cause you're [ __ ] chasing her
you're chasing her she's trying to get
the [ __ ] away from you and you're
calling her crazy
man that whole thing just the way she
when she was trying to buy gas and
everyone was just on her
uh i even cringed thinking about it
because i'm just like i would hate
i would have i would hate to be in that
position especially like to be
with your family like your family doing
that to you that's crazy
but yeah um
fame it's not it's not no one's supposed
to be famous it's not a thing especially
with all these
gadgets now we're not supposed to have
these we're not supposed to
have um
people who don't do [ __ ] with their
lives have such a loud voice in droves
being able to tell us because back in
the day i saw this quote on instagram
um yes uh maybe last week or this week
about like you know back in the day
before social media
you only heard from doers
you heard from people who were actually
doing [ __ ] you rarely heard from
complainers but now complainers are the
ones you hear from the most because they
finally have a voice and they can be
anonymous and hide behind their the
anonymity
so
yeah they're the ones who have the big
the big voice now and the doers are just
doing
so people start to eventually believe
the complainers
and a weird
paradox shift now in in this day and age
so like i said you have to be able to
sift through the noise
and i have my ways of doing that
and i guess you'd also only hear if you
go back even further from people in your
tribe
exactly really said was that we're only
supposed to have like certain amount of
people we associate with as as the human
animal but then like social media and
the connectivity we have now just made
us connected to the whole world made the
world a small place that you can just
even confirmation bias that's another
thing we have to be careful about like
and i make sure because i follow certain
people on instagram that i don't
necessarily agree with
what i follow them just to like
hear the other side i want to know man
just to like
because i don't want to be surrounded by
yes men are people like oh i only follow
uh you know this because this tells me
what i need to know what i want to hear
exactly yeah yeah so now i follow
certain people just because i'm like uh
they make me feel a certain way but i'm
like
they're not wrong though you know and
it's just different ideas it's not wrong
or writes with different ideologies but
i'm just like you know what
i'll tap into that just so i can at
least
be aware of the other side what they're
thinking yeah and that kind of brings me
to
what i heard you say about rogan when
you defended him because yeah rogan's
one of those people for me as well like
i can listen to his shows and his his
podcast and stuff and i don't have to
agree with everything of course but
there's a diverse yeah yeah i don't have
to agree with his guess what it means
but there's a diversity of opinion yeah
so i can and i feel like people these
days as we've all observed
they don't want to hear anything outside
of their own it's either left or right
and it's the other side is wrong and if
there's nothing in the middle right and
if you say one thing that represents the
other side like they just started in a
box right away but that's the thing i'm
like the
this whole
[ __ ] situation we have with coven now
and
what we're doing in society is a strange
times man because people are just
the human animals weird it's a weird
[ __ ] species because
individually we can be smart but when
we're in droves
just this dummies just a bunch of
dummies and droves sometimes i'm like
how can a smart person
have this idea about this when you know
what's really happening you really it's
like if you if you really step away from
it like you said just remove yourself
and situation and look at it from a
third person as an observer you just
watch it and just be like i know what
that is but then somehow
the smartest people i've i know
sometimes just have the weirdest way of
looking at the world and i try not to
hold it against them because i'm like i
know you you're a smart person but maybe
the way you were brought up or your own
childhood trauma again can kind of skew
the way you look at the world so i never
hold it against them i just kind of like
it's not personal it's not about me it's
about them so just observe but yes women
very weird very strange
and they're just i guess trying to fit
in too they're trying to be part of it
are you exactly tribe yeah so it's like
more mentality even with um i i remember
when andrew schultz said recently he's
like on one of his podcasts he said he
regrets getting the vaccine
and yeah he said he wishes he never did
what's like
people
i find this really strange that people
like
people don't want to get duped
people don't want to get dude people
hate feeling like they got a hat and if
people
if someone felt like oh you know they
they got duped they kind of want to get
people into their tribe something they
can
you know we've got you on our side i
don't care what side you're on i
literally don't care whether you want to
do this or you do that all i care about
is how you treat people how you treat
the people around you the people you
interact with but nah this day and age
like i find people asking me the
strangest questions like and then
they'll base their how they treat you
based on that response like are you
vaccinated that was one of the weirdest
one i was like why do you care yeah what
does that do for you well we need to
decide who you are exactly one decision
we want to know what box to play with
it's like why yeah so i like to [ __ ]
with people and just like ah maybe i am
maybe i'm not we'll find out but then
they're just like no but we need to know
about you yeah
yeah whose side are you on exactly i'm
like
why do you care yeah and this is the
thing with division as well i've said
like they did divide and conquer
that's the easiest way to break a you
know a a a nation or a group of people
just divide them and separate them make
them think that
one is on the other side and this and
that and make them fight amongst each
other that's how they've done it for
years for centuries the oligarchs or the
illuminati or whatever you want to call
it they divide and conquer that's how
they get it done so why do you think
that they're not doing that right now
in so many different ways so many
different ways
i i consider myself to be someone that
sits in the middle so like sometimes
agree i don't have to i don't [ __ ] up
politics i don't i don't so you know
nigerian parents my dad used to have cnn
or bbc on the telly all the [ __ ] time
constantly just on repeat but i just
don't watch the news i literally don't
listen to it
um
you know in new zealand we used to have
um like an update with this whole cover
[ __ ] on mondays i believe
around 5 00 p.m i never once was like on
a monday like oh yeah gotta get it
but everyone else is just like oh has
that they made the announcement yeah i'm
just like
um because i get the i get a new second
hand i'm like what do they say oh cool i
will let it because i just there wasn't
apply to me
that's how i feel i just i really and i
assess my ego talking i'm not talking
the rules of the law i'm just talking
like
no matter what they say
i can do
or i can't do
like example we were locked down
for three months last year in august
during that time those things weren't
allowed to do like train
i trained
allegedly
yeah
but i found ways like i just felt like
the rules would apply to me because i
mean in the beginning of the pandemic
trust me i was scared
i was i didn't know what this [ __ ]
[ __ ] was it felt like the purge but then
eventually after all the [ __ ] after
a year and two years i kind of like okay
like everyone else we we just knew what
was going on there's some kind of other
i guess agenda behind it that we have no
[ __ ] idea about i'm not going to act
like i [ __ ] know but i just know that
this doesn't make sense to me it does
not make sense to me that
i don't want to get too deep into all
that [ __ ] but it literally doesn't make
sense to me the common sense was just
not commenting it was not common enough
so i was like okay this is there's
something going on here that i'm not
[ __ ] with but i'm gonna live my life
the best way i know how
in the lines of what i can allegedly
i hear you
when you said at the start about the
cartwheel you said you know you just
wanted to be authentically yourself and
this kind of links to what we're saying
now when i when i was i joined bbc1 as a
dragon i started thinking about how i
defend myself from the inevitability of
being cancelled
either for the people that i speak to
here yeah and one of the ways that i
kind of concluded with my team was well
if i am always myself and i don't ever
try and convince the press that i'm a
good guy
so this is where this is the this is the
trap that a guy like john just fell into
because he was always like the pastor's
son he was always like you know
um after a fight i want to thank jesus
you know i'll be sponsored by nike and
you know all kids you know i want to be
someone kids look up to i want to be a
good role model right alright
[ __ ] them kids
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] you know what i mean
i'm like bro people say i said all you
know my kid looks up to you i'm like
raise your own damn kids
where's your own damn kids you know like
one thing
after my ufc debuted some guys so i at
my after party i had this shirt right
said good [ __ ] from engage classic sold
still big seller and some guy
oh straight up it was the beautiful
shirt like it also it was like a a play
on the famous designer brand gc like
yeah so we we we sold those we still
sell them heaps
but um this guy came up to me and he was
interviewing me at my own after party
and i could see he was trying to set me
up so that he's like oh so what do you
yeah so what do you think a t-shirt like
that sends what kind of message does it
say i'm like what do you mean and he he
thought he [ __ ] with her he [ __ ]
with the wrong one this time so he's
like what do you think that kind of
shirt sends as a message to say for
example a young a young kid who looks up
to you and i was just like oh really
oh so what does that kid look look up to
me for because i want for being in your
position as a war a fighter right yes so
that kid just saw what i did about a few
hours ago when i beat the [ __ ] out of
that guy and he saw where i was taking
me he's like no no no i was like stay
there and i could see him trying to find
a way out of that so that kid just
watched me beat this [ __ ] guy to a
pulp in his own blood as he spat blood
at me and i beat him in his own blood
till the referee dragged me off him yeah
oh really so what do you think is doing
more damage
to the kid
is is me doing that and well as and the
kid looking up to me for that or me
wearing a shirt that just says good [ __ ]
it's this whole [ __ ] culture of like
stupid language games you can say that
word and that's a bad word and this and
that so and then i i can't remember how
i flame them but i flame there was a bit
of audience as well i flamed him badly
he never released the interview
obviously because he didn't like the
standard but he thought he had me but he
didn't realize he [ __ ] with the wrong
one and i just told him i was like i
think
me doing my job
does more damage to the kid for watching
than me wearing a shirt that says good
[ __ ] you know what i mean and i hate
that the fact that we're playing these
because even when i do so i don't do new
zealand media anymore because they're
too [ __ ]
stupid for me and two like i did this
morning show one time and i was talking
and i said brother something asked his
ah that's a swear swear jaw switch on my
what the [ __ ] this is high school i'm
like i'm an adult i know you i've seen
you at [ __ ] possibly social club
drunk up your face i know what you do in
the bathroom you know what i mean so i'm
just like don't try and act like you're
holier than down now and like oh you put
that in the swear jar
it's like this whipper what what game
are we playing
you're playing this stupid game that's
like oh we can say these words but you
can't say these words like you're an
adult when the cameras go off i know how
to [ __ ] speak i know how you talk you
know and it's like why we're pretending
we don't speak the way we do because of
what because we're on tv it's just it
boggles me sometimes and i started like
oh what game are we playing it's like
it's it's so stupid as adults we're
adults like we we talk this is how this
is language we curse we swear but then
when the tv comes all you want to be
proper and you know you must you be you
know prestigious and speak i'm like nah
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] man like let's let's
speak the way we normally speak and be
authentically ourselves so that's like
charlemagne say something and say speak
your truth so long no one can use the
truth against you amen amen bro like
trust me like i
i'm able to get away with a lot of
things i get away with because i never
said i'm a saint
i know myself i am a [ __ ] demon
sometimes trust
there's no good people there's no bad
people people are just capable of great
good and great evil you know what i mean
but i just try and do more good than bad
but i have done some bad things in my
time because i'm a human being you know
what i mean so
when people try and
i guess put you in a box like oh he's a
good guy or he's this i'm like there's
no good people there's no bad people
we're just people and we're capable of
great good and great evil that's it amen
yeah i i in my head when you were saying
that and you looked me in the eyes man
i've been the demon sometimes yeah i
just had this image of your nigerian
yeah yeah
that's the thing so when i started this
podcast i know i was going to be on bbc
one at 9 00 pm on this very prestigious
show i was like by the way i used to
shoplift pizzas to feed myself when i
was broke i did this i did this i did
this and you can always out there
exactly right and you can almost in my
head when you said that i could i was
imagining the press here just packing up
their suitcases and [ __ ] off and be
like we've got we can't use him
we can't use this guy because he's not
tried to he's not trying to tell us that
he's something he's not built this big
hill of moral perfection so we gotta go
find you know we got good friends they
can't [ __ ] with me because you know why
if like there's a reason i've stayed off
tmz i've never been on tmz in knock on
wood never will for the wrong reasons
but
i mean one day if something happens i
just happen to be on tmz for the wrong
reason i'd be like whoopsie my bad i
made a mistake but guess what i never
told you i was perfect exactly i'm
normal i'm human being and so i'm just
like
that that's my power is being vulnerable
with my faults
you know i'm not going to say i've done
this i've done that but i just no i'm
not i'm not perfect i'm a human being i
make mistakes and it's okay to make
mistakes the difference between me and
some people
is that i actually learn from my
mistakes and i don't make the same
mistakes over
and over and over again in the public
eye like some people
john jones that's one that's a classic
example obviously the same [ __ ]
mistake we had a guest come on this
podcast in december and um
she said that she was making the point
about everyone having the same 24 hours
in the day this was kind of the quote
she used and it became the number one
story in this country for three days it
trended number one on twitter it was on
hundreds of newspaper articles written
about it because
i think maybe her brand is one that is
trying to be a role model so so it she
was a it was the number one trending
topic in our country for three what was
the story that she said everyone has the
same 24 hours in the day oh
right exactly so i came out and said by
the way loads of my guests say that all
the time why are you attacking that and
then my next press event right i i wore
a shirt that said 24 hours on it
everyone clapped
i didn't get cancelled and i said my
cancelled i wore a shirt and all the
paps are there didn't hours i said 24 24
hours in the shirt and this is what i'm
this is my that was my attempt again to
say by the way i'm not perfect and if
you want to cancel me please do it now
so i can come with my life yeah and i'm
still waiting they've tried they've
tried me they they keep trying me i'm
just like look
it's hard to cancel someone when they
actually
don't give a [ __ ] and they've been in
them i'm like
i fight people for money
that's what i do for a job i beat people
up for shitload of money if you really
want to take my political views on my
moral views into consideration and say
this and that and right right around
that's on you
i'm like this is i'm not i never said
i'm a saint i'm not a [ __ ] politician
i don't
everyone i don't feel like i have
anything to hide like i said i put
everything not everything but like i put
things out there that i probably
shouldn't sometimes but that's my way of
being vulnerable to the point where i'm
just like this is me take it or leave it
but i feel like me doing that
attracts the people who can relate who
can resonate and i feel like they
gravitate towards me you don't talk
about your relationships your romantic
relationships
never way nah is it because of
protecting the person or
look this world one thing i've seen is
they'll build you up right
they'll build you up and then tear you
down like a free britney
miley cyrus
justin bieber all these people i've seen
it happen so many times
so
and also this world just takes they just
take take when i have kids you'll never
know the world would never know their
face
i know i'm even contemplating if i still
give them my last name because i don't
want to put that pressure on them
because even my my siblings sometimes
they hate it as well with like you know
oh this is um this is davis israel's
brother or else's um his deborah says
israel's sister or stop being a sister
and they're like oh my name's deborah
you know like
i don't want to put that on them same
thing in my relationships that's certain
things i protect
because
i value them so i keep them safe
because the world will just try and take
take take and that's why that's one
thing everyone wants to like know what's
he doing who's he with apparently i'm
gay as well because of my nails and my
pearl necklaces and all that stuff so
i'm just like
i let them talk it's fun
but have you found it difficult because
of the success and the meteoric rise and
the money and the increased attention to
to navigate
being good in that department and also
your obsession with becoming
the man you are today which did feel
like an obsession when i was reading
about your story sleeping in the gym
yeah like how does one do that and also
balance out having your life yeah that's
regular i'm a human being and i have
feelings you know so i'm an empath as
well
yeah i'm born on the cusp so i'm like i
say i'm a cancer leo i'm hard and soft
like a semi job you know introvert
extrovert exactly my guy so a lot of
people don't realize that about myself
like when it's time to like go in my in
my in my crab hole i just find my way
i'm like right leave me on this i love
my friends because my close friends i
can we can do this for hours and just
yawn and talk [ __ ] and make fun of each
other and just show each other love but
then we can spend the next three hours
just sitting in the same room being on
my phone or watching tv or listening to
a podcast and not say a damn word and
just enjoy each other's space
i love that i love that feeling
but um
yeah i'm a person who who feels a lot so
i like to protect that i like to keep
that really
guarded because like i said the world to
take that away from you men and i feel
like people ruin things
people especially like this this
this is not supposed to happen the world
i'm being under a microscope and
everyone watching what i'm doing
so certain things i just have i feel
like i just have to really protect
because i don't want the world to take
that away from me because they just take
take
my cat died um
maybe two years ago
the morning she died right i was i think
i was filling gas up in the afternoon
and some guy came up while i'm feeling
gas and goes
brother bro can you talk to my cousin
real quick he's a big fan i'm just like
man bro my cat just died this morning
man i'm not alone in the mood and i
remember the look on his face just like
oh
right all good all good whatever
i was like ah give me the phone i said
hello
and this is as i'm filling gas actively
and i was like
hold up bro
no phones
like what what if i spontaneously but
they don't care they just want to have
their moment they want to take they want
to take they want to take so that's why
if i'm having dinner with my family if
i'm on a date if i'm in the intimate
moment people start to like
bro i don't want to be that guy but i'm
like but you're being that guy you're
being that guy you say you don't want to
be there but you're being that guy
that's what people say i'm not a racist
i've got yeah oh yeah bro
i hate to be that guy but can i i'm like
well you're being that guy you hate to
be that guy boy you're doing it right
now and it's like i'll be having lunch
with you and within
10 minutes we'll get stuck probably like
six times with you and probably if we if
we had lunch in london we'd probably not
even have a chance to talk but they
don't care they just want to get their
picture and put on their [ __ ]
social media with [ __ ] 20 followers
saying oh look at me
like whatever i'm just like no let me
have my moment i'm i'm
and i've learned this i okay my
experience with this and i always bring
this up whenever i see him on
on tv or hairs raps most deaf
i see most deaf and common in auckland
airport
and they're having a conversation by the
by the back carousel
and i want to fight in adelaide and i'm
coming back home i had my trophy and i
was like oh i want to get a picture and
i pull up to him i'm like
hey what's up most left big fan he's
like hey brother just no photos today
man i was just like yeah all good no
worries easy now i remember
i was a bit sad
but i understood
i understood because they were in a bit
in the middle of a conversation actively
talking i should have had
the
etiquette to realize like just
they talking leave them alone but this
is a thing no one i feel like it's
learned behavior as well that's the one
thing because i everyone thinks that
your biggest fan it's the same rhetoric
i know the lines they're gonna say
each time but like
it's alert behavior i don't know i think
it's maybe from
tv or disney or whatever
people feel like when when you meet
someone you really you're a fan of you
yell at them
to let them know how much of a fan you
are and you show them
by just shaking and
i honestly think it's learned behavior
because
sometimes i'm like there's no need for
all this
i'll be at like a three i'm chilling at
a two or three at a park and so
no [ __ ] way
oh my god
ah i'm just like
okay after the whitaker fight the first
one
i remember after that whole
the fight
after the after party on the way back to
the uh back to new zealand i remember at
the airport i put out a story just
saying like look if you see me
at the airport or traveling
just approach me lightly because if you
come at me with
all this energy i'll walk away i put
that on my story just because i was like
i'll walk away because my capacity to
deal with high energy right now was just
how are you feeling i was just drained
i was drained so i was just i just want
to go home and chill so i remember at
the airport i just i was before at the
hotel i put up before i went to the
airport i just put that out there on the
story just to be like look
don't come at me with all this [ __ ]
because it's too much for me to deal
with right now so if you come at me just
like hey what's up bro big fan can i
take a photo that's cool
and i remember that fight week the week
before the fight week i realized i had
an epiphany i realized i don't have to
match everyone's energy
because that was a problem i used to
like if you're a fan you meet me and i
feel hey even if i made it like i said
my cat just died then i'd have to like
raise my level up hey what's up bro hey
do the whole song and dance and
all that [ __ ] i'm like nah i don't have
to match everyone's energy
because guess what hard pill to swallow
i'm not excited to meet you
as much as you are to meet me
it's just a hard pill to swallow and
it's just my everyday life i'm not
excited to meet you as you are to meet
me and that's okay because this is my
life this is how i deal with things so
once i once i kind of like go over that
hump i was like oh i don't have to match
everyone's energy so if someone comes to
me out of 10
i don't have to raise my level up i can
i'm just chilling i'm listening to a
podcast i can just pause and be like
what's up man how are you doing and if
they feel like that's a [ __ ] interaction
cool that's their prerogative i don't
care
but if i'm
if you met me last night like i'm
[ __ ] i'm in the streets in london
last night i'm showing love to everyone
i'm dancing i'm talking to people i'm
i'm mr you know mr area boy
but
that's a time and place i'm taking
pictures and you know all that kind of
stuff there's a time and place if you
catch me at the right time and place
[ __ ] i'll show you love but i hate when
people get entitled and think they just
i want to take i want to take
so that's why i keep
yeah
quick one as you might know crafted are
one of the sponsors of this podcast and
they make really meaningful pieces of
jewellery this lion piece they've made i
wear all the time along with the little
timepiece the sand timer that i wear
often and the lion piece you might have
seen conor mcgregor has a similar piece
which was custom made for him for me it
represents courage and if you walk
through my house the house that i'm in
right now if you walk six feet in that
direction you'll see a huge lion
portrait if you go upstairs you'll see a
lion portrait if you look behind me on
the shelf near the top there you'll see
a line as well the reason my house and
my life is surrounded by lions is
because they represent courage
calmness and that tenacity that i've
applied to my business success to my
professional life into everything in
between for me the lion has always been
an animal that can be almost a bit of a
contradiction they are so loving and so
caring of their own and can be powerful
and courageous when necessary in order
to achieve what they want to achieve so
if you like me are a big fan of courage
bravery ambition while also being
calm and composed check out this line
piece and let me know if you get it and
you keep your boys and your the people
you came up with close right
tell me about the import how how much
you realize the importance of that as
you've risen to this place you know to
keep
the day ones around you and stuff like
that i mean you you'll know this it's
lonely at the top
you know but it's not if you bring the
right people with you
the people that came up with you the
people that
you know love you for you you know the
people that know you from before you had
money
before you were famous you know so
um i like to have them around to keep me
grounded to keep me grounded and just
make sure i'm i'm solid because they
knew me before any of this [ __ ] happens
and
you know it's hard because sometimes you
i i have fallen into the trap of having
people who just agree with me
yes man
you know and
even my boy chance i'm glad like i have
him around because sometimes
i'm crazy i don't always have the best
ideas and i'll have an idea he'll be
like nah
but okay cool i just needed someone to
tell me no
but i'll put it out there boy if he's
like nah we're not doing that okay cool
because then it just helps me but if i
have people around me which is like uh
okay sure then
eventually it just makes me more
powerful and i just start to think like
oh yeah you know i'm the [ __ ] i can say
whatever i want and that's not that's
not healthy man i don't think that's
healthy for
the ego you know
yeah
well i just like having people like that
around me because i feel like
yeah they keep me grinding and just
remind me where i come from you know
they're and
there's so many stories man each of my
friends in my group chat i've known each
of them over 10 years
but
well over 10 years and we all have
stories we can kind of share from back
in the day that just just remind me
where i come from yeah
and the other thing that happens is when
you reach what the heights you've
reached in your profession is we talked
about it then you have this other
um
this other attention which is from women
that might want you for the wrong
reasons oh yeah my mom always wants me
to have a baby
my mom's trying to tell me it's like you
know i want anger to set it down
when are you going to find a nice
nigerian
i don't settle so for me
um
that that's something i guess you just
you just have to take it by case-by-case
basis yeah case-by-case basis because
you do find people who just some people
play the long game put it that way
i'm bad people played a long game with
me even recently
it's just like yeah you know they
there's love there and all that kind of
stuff but they play a long game because
they see the value
and it's not just
what you this is what you bring to the
table and they get entitled
you know and i feel like that's that's
not the way you want to be when you have
someone you know that's that you're
romantically in love with or involved
with as you don't want to be competing
with them or have them feel entitled to
what you have i'm like yo you just got
here
i've been made it the [ __ ] are you
talking about what do you bring to the
table i bought the [ __ ] table what
values are you looking for do you look
for in in that kind of person kind i
just like someone who's caring who gives
a [ __ ] who really cares like and who
wants nothing from me
that's the thing it's hard to find with
someone who needs nothing even for me i
don't even celebrate my birthday and i'm
hard to buy gifts for because i'm not
really a material i love material things
obviously
but nice watch yeah thank you i'm sure
you know
we work yeah
now but yeah like i'm not a material
person but i do like material things but
it's hard to buy gifts for me because
i found this as well with my rich
friends when i was coming up it was hard
to buy gifts for them when someone
you're able to buy whatever they want
so boy and that and that i just look for
souls who's who's caring someone who
really gives a [ __ ] that's the main
thing do you give a [ __ ] about me yeah
and you're gonna have a family one day
of course that's my that's definitely
one of my main goals after this
i don't want to be that dad that's like
you know i wake up
see my kids for like 30 minutes before i
go to work
and then when i finish work i see them
like for hour hour and a half maybe
while i'm tired
no
i'm gonna make sure i'm there from the
ages of zero to five or six i'm gonna be
like what do you wanna do today
like literally what do you wanna and i
feel honestly
[ __ ] school i don't know why we still
even have this whole
[ __ ]
this this outdated concept of school to
just build workers
because we know what the [ __ ] school was
made for why are we pretending we know
school was created to create workers do
you still know i don't what the [ __ ] is
x no [ __ ] idea i'm still waiting
still i don't like when have i in my
life as an adult knowing what the [ __ ] x
is
no [ __ ] idea a lot of useless
information got passed on to me in
school
and i sucked at school because i was
[ __ ] at memorizing same i didn't really
learn anything dropouts as we do cheers
drop out my man
school doesn't teach you much honestly
teaches you the basics i understand math
yes english comprehension all that kind
of stuff but when you come to like
social studies and algebra and calculus
i'm like are you gonna use those in the
real world
so fox go my plan is right
when i have kids
i'm going to have a tutor
that's going to teach them from their
age at home from from the time like say
maybe
9 00 a.m
to midday
or 1 p.m and they'll have an hour of
homework and the rest of the day will
just go on adventures doing [ __ ] but
then
they're going to do gymnastics
compulsory because i want to make sure
they know their body the foundation of
athleticism gymnastics
and jiu-jitsu so that way they're
involved with other kids and not
socially awkward mm-hmm you don't want
to raise some [ __ ] pumpkins who
you know don't have any social skills
but yeah yeah i want to make sure that
they have those kind of skills by
interacting with other kids through
gymnastics
or through jiu jitsu or other like
activities and they'll do that every day
or every whatever day of days of the
week it is but
school going there clocking in sitting
down
watching a teacher write some [ __ ] on
the board and write right around no
one's teaching just literally some of
these people just there to catch a
paycheck and i've seen it i was in
school you just see them there oh
they'll write the [ __ ] on the board
whatever copy this copy exactly copy
this i don't even know what because
we're doing these when i was in high
school ncaa credits and i remember just
like towards the end of the year what's
all this credits credits credits not to
repeat the whole year
well i didn't know what i was like
credit what ncea credits what's all this
credit [ __ ] credit credit credit credit
i did not care i didn't understand i i
just didn't fathom it but then
eventually when i go to grasp it i was
like oh
this sucks it's a [ __ ] system and then
they'll give you the d and then you'll
feel like you're a d as a human you're
dead exactly
bro i'm stupid one of the worst ones i
remember was in
in boarding school in nigeria i was i
was bottom three in the class and of
course they'll have to announce it the
bottom three you have to stand in front
of the school now
just like
these are the bottom three
with your head down yep that's us that's
yeah we had the weather once i was the
lowest yes thank you
okay now go and take your seats okay yes
thank you oh the worst man that's just
humiliating but it's like it's i don't
know if it's meant to motivate you or
walk but i didn't do [ __ ] and like i
said a lot of people said like if i see
that now even like
young people just have to tie this
self-worth
i have a friend in med school who
literally like when it gets crunch time
they just like i need to get these
grades and get their grades up and they
just identify themselves if i don't get
this i'm useless this is it i failed i'm
like you're 23. calm the [ __ ] down
it's not that deep it is obviously it's
your career but i'm like there's more to
life
there's way more life than this than
than just this
idea of who you think you are because
when i was [ __ ] 18 i thought i was
gonna be married and have kids at 23.
boy was i wrong damn i'm like how to
[ __ ] who let me buy a house now i'm like
why i don't know who let me do that i
shouldn't should have never given these
[ __ ] money
first of all
i don't think they gave it to you yeah i
took all that
i'm a bankroll but yeah like
yeah i i don't know what i was thinking
back then i thought like this i thought
i knew what i wanted so when i was 18 i
was i'm going to have kids when i'm 23
24. [ __ ] hell excuse me
when you look forward to your your
you've i mean you've reached the top of
your game um
how do you how do you keep yourself
you know what is it the thing that's
driving you now what is the thing you're
aiming for now what's that north star
that's getting you out of bed
is it lego
people talk about legacy legacy yeah big
thing that's what it is
for me is definitely the legacy i want
to live why does that matter
i think i want to be immortal i don't
know if it's my ego or i'm selfish or
what it is but i i just know
look i dissonant the prefix idea is
royalty where we're from you know idea
from the robot from the urban tribe you
know that's
that's some royal blood tied to it i dis
on you
but now worldwide the name addisonya is
synonymous with greatness
forever synonymous with greatness and
i'm gonna make sure that is i'm gonna
make sure if you have that name like
this one and you're proud to be like yep
i'm tied to that bloodline i understand
because
i don't know i don't know what it is is
it my ego why is it that [ __ ]
king tut wanted to be buried in his tomb
with all his gold even though he's not
going to be there to exactly enjoy it i
don't know i don't know but i know when
it's all said and done when i'm dead
my name will be remembered in history
what's that troy line
and that's why no one will remember your
name or whatever it was but like i want
to make sure that my name will be
remembered and revealed throughout
history as one of the
one of the best in this game but also
just as a person i just just just the gc
just a good [ __ ] just a happy dude who
was who was enjoying life and just
i don't know making [ __ ] happen but it's
more about the feeling though i want
people to remember my name and just
remember the feeling i gave them
you know what i mean
like those who are alive to what or not
life or around to watch jordan's um
reign in the nba i mean i'm sure when
they hear jordan they can just i
remember that time i was at that game or
i remember that time i watched that that
game live and they remember the feeling
i want those like when they remember my
name
to be like i was there 243 i remember
how i was in the in the arena when he
won that feeling i want i want people
forget what you say or what you do but
they never forgot how you make them feel
so it's the feeling i want to make sure
they remember yeah when people reach the
top of their game they start becoming
philanthropists we see this when people
get villains they think because they
they can't seem to get the buzz or the
feeling anymore from um from business or
successful money or lamborghinis you've
got so they start like helping other
people right i'm getting there you're
getting to the point where you're
starting to feel that the greatest
service you can do is like for others
because when you're talking about your
legacy there it's actually sounds like
the feeling that's feeling philanthropy
it's like i want to leave this feeling
with other people so that they feel you
know inspired or whatever yeah um i i'm
doing the same thing so i'm setting my
people up the people in my circle i'm
not handing anything out to them but
just with opportunities
you know and also experiences i'm giving
them experiences to inspire them um
but yeah there's things that i do
behind the scenes that i don't
necessarily
i don't know like i'm not one of these
guys i don't do it for the likes i do it
for love
and i feel like there's a bar from jay-z
the best form of giving is anonymous to
anonymous
so there's ways i just
i drop gems like shaq i love the way
shaq does it but he does it quite overly
he's like you want a bike yeah
[Music]
ask your mom if you can have a bike
you got these shoes how many do you want
you know like
it does like just drop jams everywhere
it makes people happy because if it
feels good to make people feel good
even though that is selfish in a sense
because i'm getting i'm getting
something i'm getting good feels out of
it but still i'm making someone feel
good
i'd rather that but i'm not doing it to
be like
yeah man you know i know you're hungry
and
i just bought you this meal because i
really want to show love to you man you
know
yeah exactly and upload it to the gram
and then [ __ ] yeah i don't do that like
there's things i've done even
tim will tell you after this i mean even
for this fight there was someone that i
i think last year he went through some
stuff that i heard about on on the media
and i was just like [ __ ] i went through
that [ __ ] as well
and then this fight i brought him out
and i showed him a good time yeah he and
his mom and i i i put them up got some
tickets and just made sure they um yeah
they were looked after i met him
backstage and
just gave him a few words of
encouragement and i don't need to bring
it up because yeah yeah okay how are you
it's fine thank you yeah yeah but tim
will tell you about it when you walked
in this song playing
do you remember the song thing hold up
oh victory like oh no that was a lipsy
yeah yeah um which one was one it was
from victory lap though yeah yeah
yeah double up double up yeah every time
that song gets me every time yeah when
it gets to the course i live in p.m
when you let me oh it gets me man every
single time i don't know why about
something about that track
it just gets me in my field i didn't
even think about it and i get goosebumps
yeah
double lobster track man
when i saw you
pre-fight playing that song
[Music]
crying yeah
and then i saw you in the stands another
time crying yeah i guess that was the
evidence that you are a bit of an empath
you do feel i feel like the last one was
that was when i watched my boy blood
diamond jump on the scale
to weigh in um
and i get really emotional fight week's
like my wedding week i feel this is why
i dread getting married because i don't
the guest list i'm just like i don't
even [ __ ] know who i want to like
invite because people are going to be
like
ready
i just want to celebrate my birthday
because it's like
a few times a year there's a whole week
that everything's about me
so i don't need another special day that
it's about me so that's why i'm also
dreading like i said my wedding day or
my birthday first fun exactly so i
really don't celebrate my birthday to be
honest like
every day is my birthday i can do
whatever [ __ ] i want you know i don't
even sell i don't i don't buy gifts for
people on their birthday i just buy them
if i see something that's uh i think
she'll like that i think he'll value
that i'll just buy it just because i'm
like oh give them the experience just
because that's like they'll value that
but um i know you're not missing
valentine's day though oh no
sometimes
i have a special traditional vantage
that i used to do but i can't i don't
really play around with it anymore i
just used to like just mad memes on my
page and just
just it's funny i was just awake the
first time i did it was in 2014
yes i believe 2014 valentine's day i was
fighting and throughout the day i was
waiting for the fight i was just bored
it's before stories on instagram so i
just put up like 80 posts that day just
like yeah i know people got mad at me
people were really entertained but i
didn't care i was just i was just in
that fight mode so i was just like
[ __ ] putting a post
just memes and just making just making
fun of valentine's day but [ __ ] good
times a good time before i was uh
i guess super famous
one of our guests you said you're going
up to manchester un on the weekend one
of our guests patrice everest manchester
united football legend
do you know the guy no i see i don't
football the bug didn't catch me yeah he
didn't catch me sports didn't really
catch me as a kid because i was
unathletic funny enough
yeah i know i was never really athletic
kid yeah
mad i mean patrice when patrice came
here he he's from his family from africa
originally moved to france played the
french football team he became this
legend maybe the greatest manchester
united wing back in our history um
he wrote a question in the diary um we
always get our i guessed the right
questions right yes i heard about this
and this is all i knew about this
podcast i was okay apparently there's a
question yeah yeah
there's a question at the end but in
fact i'm gonna read you the question
that's been left for you by i don't
actually read it until i look at it but
um patrice asked a question which i
thought was really profound because i
remember being asked this question one
day it really puzzled me it's such a
simple question so we'll ask you the
question okay
are you
happy
right now yes yes i'm very happy why'd
you say right now
because it's not lasting it's fleeting
that's one thing i've also learned as
well is
well you can't enjoy the sunshine
without a little rain
and everything is temporary everything
everything's forever changing so even
right now i'm happy
i'm enjoying life i love where i'm at i
love who i'm around i love who i'm with
you know i
i know it's not it's not lasting because
guess what something's gonna happen
that's gonna shake that up
because back in the day whenever this is
happening i'm just like i spent a few
good days
things are so nice
where's the thing that's gonna [ __ ] me
up but not now i'm just like
this is nice and i'll just sit in it and
i'll just enjoy it i enjoy the happiness
and i enjoy what i'm doing to enjoy
where i'm at
and then when the bad thing comes i'm
like ah there it is it's okay this is
gonna pass as well this too shall pass
so when i say yeah i'm happy right now
i'm happy very happy are you good at
defending that happiness because because
the amount of you even described it when
you came off after your debut the amount
of people that are going to want to talk
to you and do an interview in israel
israel are you good at saying no no
better i'm better at it now i never used
to be this is where i was talking about
the people pleaser thing back in the day
and this is why this year
one of my things is i don't get [ __ ]
up around people i don't like i don't
know
cause i realize when i get drunk
i'm too nice i'm a friendly drunk i'm
like a [ __ ] golden retriever
when i'm drunk or black labrador i'm
just like hey and not everyone's your
friend not everyone wants the best for
you but they'll just take advantage and
try and like you know
i just let my boundaries get crossed too
many times you know and i let people get
too close maybe like two
then the next day i'm just like what the
[ __ ] did i let that person
you know ah [ __ ] i wish i'd said no to
that you know then i started like
they'll eat at me for the next few days
so
yeah um i i'm getting
and it's practice it's constantly
evolving but i know how to say no no i
just say and i don't have to explain
myself
i literally just say no because when
you're explaining yourself you're losing
i learned that from chill sudden i
remember when i used to listen to his
podcast he said something really
profound like when you're explaining
yourself you're losing so i don't
explain myself i just say no if that's
like someone like can i get a phone call
i'm like i'm busy oh please i'm like no
because it's like first of all you see
i'm having i'm on a date right now and i
said no or i'm walking with someone
right now i'm having an intimate moment
and you're disturbing my peace so i say
no and if you try and like push push
okay no
and something like oh [ __ ] you know
they'll say something stupid all will
[ __ ]
rubble smash you anyway or whoever your
next opponent is i was like huh okay
then i just let them you know this is
why they take a photo with you boy if
they sometimes at a restaurant like if i
say no to someone because i'm having
lunch or i'm on a date or whatever and
then they come up to me and it's like
i'm busy right now man
if they leave me alone
on my way out if i see that person
and they were and they were nice and
respectful i'd be like yo you have your
phone on you then we'll take a photo
because i'm like thanks for being
respectful because sometimes i can
understand people's judgment goes out
the way when they see a celebrity
apparently
and i felt this way like i said you just
don't realize your etiquette it's just
so when when that happens i don't hold
it against them i'm like it's learned
behavior like i said so then i'll
yeah i'll take my time out of my uh out
of my day and just say what's up
afterwards but if they like you know oh
please please
i'm like bro you're not respecting my
boundaries you didn't respect my no i
need my note to be respected i said no
why because i [ __ ] said so that's it
i didn't explain myself to you who the
[ __ ] are you i don't know you're from a
bar soap and again
you're more excited to meet me than i am
to meet you
in in the core of your being do you
realize that you're a star yeah i always
knew so i i knew i wasn't gonna be
regular i just knew like i was gonna be
great at something
i didn't know what it was
but i knew i was going to be great at
something i just knew even when i was
working my my last job i just i i'm
grateful for it because it showed me
what i didn't want in life
i just knew this isn't for me and what
is that is that self-belief that gets
you there or is that
so is it is it you believing that you're
gonna be great that got you there or is
it because you were innately destined to
be great i'm trying to figure out if
it's something that one what came first
the chicken or the egg yeah um there's
levels there's people like us we're
crazy in the sense that we believe
to be it's almost delusional sometimes
yes like what's the one
i've heard this quote on the jre before
it's like greatness and madness and
next-door neighbors and they just borrow
each other sugar once in a while
you know what i mean so there's a point
like i've used the story of me when i
drive this beat up honda and i'd shift
the the gear stick and not just do this
[Music]
i literally was madness i was me
preparing for having a sports car paddle
shifts so i shifted you know three boom
gear four boom and when i dropped down
you know same thing just like i was
getting ready i was i was this is my i
brought i can manifest like a
[ __ ]
do you believe in it in in the
metaphysical like yep since you believe
100
everything comes from the imagination
everything comes from like
before this microphone was a microphone
someone
somehow thought about it now how can i
speak into something that would amplify
my voice and blah blah blah and then
this came out of it and it's evolved
over the years but everything comes from
the imagination so the power of the mind
people don't understand we still don't
understand i still understand how
powerful it is i'm still learning but i
know one thing is i can make things
happen
i can go into levels
i just can't tell the world but like
there's levels that like
i've manifested things that i'm just
like i still shock myself like how the
[ __ ] did i make that happen and this is
not even to do with fighting this is to
do in my personal life and i'm like
i made that happen and this is through
this like manifesting subconsciously as
well
just years of something just manifesting
manifesting in boom it's right there i'm
just like
[ __ ] i really made that happen it's
scary man it's scary for me to even
think about
i
reflect on that and almost view it like
getting in your car in the morning when
you get in the car in the morning you
set the sat nav
but then you've also got a drive you've
also got to go to training yeah if you
just set the sat nav where you're going
to be
sitting in the car sitting in the face
so you can sit there and make all these
dreams and manifest but you have to work
and what happens if you just try to work
if you drive and with no sat nav you
don't know where you're going you're
lost you know i mean you have no
direction so for me i feel like
both of them together
when you really when you have the vision
and you're able to manifest but then you
also put the work in
magic happens man magic that's where the
magic is but a lot of people never get
there unfortunately a lot of people
we're blessed that we can dream and
we're blessed that we can dream that's
one thing i've realized because a lot of
people
even from the impoverished parts of
london will be will be lucky to have my
old job
you know from where i'm from from
nigeria a lot of people will be blessed
to have my old job and they'll be like
yo this is i have a great job i can send
money back home this and that
but
yeah i just had bigger dreams i just
knew what i wanted so i feel like i'm
spoilt that i can i can
dream the way i i do and i can manifest
the way i do so i never take it for
granted and i realize the position that
i'm in i'm privileged i'm very
privileged
i wrote a quote about about immigrants
specifically from nigeria and it said
our parents role was to try and figure
out survival and we're here sat blessed
with the task of self-actualization
which is like figuring out meaning yeah
and they said what a beautiful thing
that is yeah they're just trying to
survive or find a way to the next way to
thrive and to educate you and see like
what's meaning and exactly happiness and
that's why i feel like even today the
way the world is like the problems of
that we have especially with all this
divisiveness and whatnot i'm like you
guys aren't really having any real
problems like when people in new zealand
start to complain about some stuff i'm
like you guys are really worried about
this it's like because there's no real
problem
the police aren't trying to kill the
people constantly you know the
government isn't
well they are [ __ ] people over but
not the same way as you know nigerians
have been focused by their government
for so long so it's like you really
having any real problems it's like they
find things to to fight about now like
now we're arguing about genders
you know this kind of stuff and it's
like because there's no really they're
looking for problems they're creating
problems look if there was some real
[ __ ] going on like this there was like
another war world war three apparently
it's coming soon stay tuned stay tuned
yeah if that was happening or aliens
invaded
do you think anyone will give a [ __ ]
about any of that [ __ ]
[ __ ] no no way we're worried about some
real [ __ ] happening you know so yeah i
feel like people just start to create
problems because we don't we need we
need struggle
we need struggle in our lives that's the
thing
most out there who's the head of google
and he changed my life for something he
said about that he said um
um unhappiness is when your expectations
of how life is supposed to be going go
unmet so it explains why a billionaire
when his state comes and it's not
perfectly cooked he will be [ __ ]
furious because his expectation was here
and if it goes unmet the delta is
unhappiness and if you go to where i was
from in botswana getting a bowl of rice
expectation is i'm not going to eat
today bowl of rice the delta is
happiness and it's the same thing you're
talking about with people you know their
problems are relative to their
expectations
right facts the last question this one
was written for you in the diary by our
previous guest what question
do you believe
based on the subject matter of the
conversation we've had today would have
been
interesting to ask you that people don't
usually ask you
i mean you touched on a few things that
normally don't even talk about
like
relationships and
kids a little bit that's stuff that i
really hold guarded but
some funny ones in my headphone i'm
gonna talk about those
go for those ones
let me see
um
i think diving into my my personal life
a little bit anything that has to do
with like family relationships or
you know
like i said yeah family that i'm gonna
have uh
i'm glad people don't though because
like i said i like to just keep those
things guarded but yeah and i think
people kind of get
my love life's not for sale my family's
not for sale those kind of things like i
said i won't i won't sell
for the consumption of people to watch
i'm not the kardashians you know i ain't
kanye west i ain't putting all my
business out there yeah so for me yeah i
keep those things guarded so
i think people kind of respect that i
understand that so they don't push too
much or you get like a little bit here
every now and then but not nothing too
much yeah thank you for your time today
it's fun to see you
in this manner like yeah you're a killer
in so many ways but we didn't even get
to talk about the marketing and the
branding side of things oh that's levels
there's ways yeah i mean
i did computer graphic design in college
and i felt like
some of the stuffs i learned
there really helped me with my social
media when it comes to making my own
highlights when i was coming up you know
posting all the anime stuff as well yeah
but that's just me being a big kid
itself is exactly authentic expression
of self
if you put it out there those who
appreciate will gravitate [ __ ] i like
that's a bar
t-shirt
yeah that's a bar those who appreciate
will gravitate i'm going to keep them
let's do yeah
add to your t-shirt collection yeah tell
them well but listen thank you so much
for your time feel great your humility
and your openness as well it means a lot
yeah likewise my man
i'm going to look into you a little bit
more you okay
this is the thing whenever i like to
meet new people and learn about them so
hearing your story i'm just like man
that's still i'm like 700 million at 27.
i think i'll leave it but yeah
thank you thank you
oh
[Music]
you